but remember less time like when peace
be with you
welcome to the Dean show on hold on hold
on hold on
welcome to goddess TV and a version of
the Dean show we are with shade use of
Estes I'm guide of Stevie Dee show live
we got a live studio audience and we're
going to be asking some tough questions
the time is short and we got to get with
it we got to my left should be to my
right but to my left over here we start
with Josh Evans Joshua Evans retired
sorry and Sheikh Yusuf Estes and we
begin with peace Salam alaikum
all right so we got some questions now
not to waste time you know go straight
into a serious business now this is
serious business
on the D Chiron goddess TV channel 99
channel 99 on world TV channel in 19 on
galaxy and also channel 25 on galaxy
every day Robby's Mike sure yeah okay so
now though we have some questions then
the D show audience and also from our
live audience here now first we want to
know the people want to know there you
guys you know we have a lot of not yet
Muslims out their potential miss somes
you know you know that Islam is the
fastest growing their life in the world
today yet most misunderstood so we want
to clear many of these misconceptions
that on the minds of the people so one
thing that we have people want to know
now you guys have any affiliation with
Osama Obama or al-qaeda now this is for
anybody anybody can take the mic NASA
and so that you mentioned may need of
the Muslim the majority of the founders
of the Muslim world
identify him as being someone who has
run outside of the the guidance of his
land and it so much they all want to add
some to that Joshua Evans use of Estes
I'm having okay so we're going to
continue on now leading into the next
question this question is similar to the
one we just add that we just asked tell
us if the the the question is asking if
now for says now I'm going to just kind
of add my own twist to it okay if
because it's time with the shoe bomber
the underwear bomber and the Time Square
bomber yeah so if the shoe bomber
because we have all these types of
bombers or the underwear bomber the
pajama bomber or the Times Square bomber
was to come to you for some advice
before one of these incidences happen
how would you talk to and address the
issue with this individual to prevent
something like this
violence to solve any issue in the big
something that they're Muslim the first
thing I tell them is that Boston wine
completely they have to be crazy
psychological things they are attempting
to do in piloting the very position
which they are professing commit even if
they say because there is not one single
iota of evidence from any authentic
religion where they're just teaching in
a center that allows us to violence
against innocent people to vent our
anger or political agendas it is not
possible to expect the only type of
aggression that is allowed as spam is in
defense of human life dignity and
justice and this is very clear the
teachings of this meant that to
associate even the words that they use
in the terminology they use you know
that you have to be born from Muslims a
viable worth of Muslims - we know
extract the revenge
because on this episode of the Dean show
on guidance TV we Sheikh Yusuf Estes
Matar Sabri and Joshua Evans we know
that you Sheikh Yusuf Estes and and this
I think is directed to you and actually
it can pass on because all of you were
former Christians and now you have by
your own free choice you decided to be
Muslims and simply a Muslim is one who
surrenders submits to the one God so did
any of your family members the question
in there is asking disowned you because
of this decision that you made in your
lives and some of them were kind of nice
Christians to start with but I put a
pressure on their packing it up you know
follows Christianity here's the Bible
this is what we got to do and when they
come in the line and start really
getting serious about it and then all of
a sudden ice
assignments like oh man so yeah in this
but they deliver home to love my father
became my song my stepmother she said
that the first second she had a regular
Porsche guys and since then had much
better relationship really wouldn't my
family okay honey I've not had much
opposition for my family actually my new
leaf and the early coming out was just
my mother and how she took her she had
the three months before see you turns
over I'm digital domicile really how
many bins up for me and for her in fact
when I left my daughter called her back
and she died in Iran on the oval July so
for me that was like confirmation read
affirmation this is in fact the truth
honey I'm pretty much the same I really
didn't broadcast - time to my family
right away I just began to change when
they saw the change in the behavior when
I became a better son even a grandson
better person individually they were
question
you know what has changed that UN is
this change real then I let them know
that has changed next question a son of
the minds of the people people want to
know now our next questioner is asking
why do muslims so that God didn't have a
son and that Jesus is not God take it
away death and the day of judgment the
mercy of Allah these are the things that
finally made me realize there is no time
to delay anymore I want you to take
martial heart of right there the essence
of spirituality is to become were
sincere to Allah subhanAllah
but to protect itself it is very very
scary but it brings you back to reality
there is a life which is everlasting and
if you have and you have to make a
conscious decision of which a group of
people do you want to be people in
heaven or the people of hell
[Music]
I am Not Afraid you stand alone if it
lies beside I am Not Afraid to stand
alone I am Not Afraid to stand alone I
am Not Afraid
[Music]
why do muslims say that god didn't have
a son and that Jesus is not God take it
away it's very clear that a lot said so
this isn't an option for a Muslim if you
understand what karate means you
understand it is the actual speaks of
all names of God in Arabic language and
in and he said in business I brought my
own means quote say who Allah who I've
had he's above any uniquely 108 dish
doesn't have this kind of one by the way
we say wanted would mean one and our
make you say what head but when you say
ahead this is meaning a word that there
isn't going to be a to coming after all
whose side this means Allah is totally
independent of this creation but the
creation needs him all through eternity
now listen here lamb now lamb is kind of
like no way Jose
okay laughs yeah Italy for sure he's not
the father of anybody well then you're
not he's not the son of anybody when I'm
yup would put one eye and he's not like
anything that you could ever imagine
nothing in the creation is not
inspiration he's not the creation like
Hindus believe or some of the others he
is totally independent of this creation
and then again it says let you know who
won uh he is unique so I think it's
pretty clear why we would say that
because I like I said he doesn't have a
son and he did not get his son and that
is a man and his son as a man
chauvinistic religion their words the
ladies in them and babies don't ponder
men though they know they come ladies so
what you say is from when we looked at
these we understand that the words
spoken about Jesus or legend spoke about
Jesus
sometimes regarded as they read that
verse with read that is printed in the
New Testament are to be his words you
never find the Prophet Jesus speak
behind ever refer to himself as the Son
of God he always refers to himself as
the Son of Man as the Son of Man and the
term sons of God were from throughout
the Bible in many many places so Jesus
was the only one called him but even in
the Old Testament some of the prophets
were called something but this was a
metaphorical expression it didn't mean
that God physically sired a son through
the agency of a female but how many left
so we refer to Jesus as he saw himself
as the Son of Man and we worship the one
whom he worship for me
all the nature of the top ten reasons
why Jesus cannot be guarding but cannot
be a man but realistically is because
there is no religious scripture anywhere
that makes this claim from any prophet
of God this is coming from other sources
and very clearly when we look at the
teachings of God throughout the entire
of the Old Testament he never teaches
this theory God is one unique when we
read what is it called the famous
statement that is in the Old Testament
which is known the Jewish
well resides thing the thing respect
every Sabbath
here o Israel the Lord your God is one
in Deuteronomy yes and it's in and this
is as you describe the oneness that is
described in the Hebrew language is a
very similar to the Arabic language and
it's very clear that this is the exact
same teacher that Jesus himself for it
means when they asked him what was the
greatest commandment what are you saying
he said well I'll tell you the first
commandment is to hear who either the
Lord your God is one the Lord your God
is one and that oneness that he referred
to is very very clear without knowing
the verse by verse by verse by first we
just have to understand this one is that
you were speaking about it is very
similar to what he said the word in the
edited language we have a number for one
rights what is the what is the word for
the number one none of it what correct
yes audience Ronnie if I take walking
and I had it to walk like it I get his
name I get to but the word in the Hebrew
language is synonymous to the word in
Arabic language that Jesus himself used
in the anime
is an advocate he said that hero either
the Lord your God is one in reference to
the exact same word I had know if you
take a head which symbolizes a unique
one is which the chip users full or not
and you think I haven't you addict I
haven't you get you can you can't the
very I never get one without the
possibility of addition or subtraction
it is a one all home by itself and this
is who God thought that he was
throughout the entirety of the Old
Testament and this to Jesus talk God was
so to say that Jesus called himself the
Son of God goes in contradiction to the
very teachings he came to professor very
teaching he professed about God there's
one more things like this by the way if
you want more clarification there's a
website we have called nine one one
Bible nine one one Bible calm and it
says son of who read article they're
moving on to the next question with our
wonderful guests our wonderful panel
here now we're here to university
broadcasting live and and I think many
can relate to this now okay basically
paraphrasing the question the questioner
is asking you know they can understand
he can or she can understand the the the
simple teachings of Islam pure
monotheism worshiping the one creator
and not his creation they can understand
the concept of accountability paradise
hellfire reward if you do the good
things that guy's telling you
but now the individual is saying you
know that many people go to college for
the experience now if I accept Islam if
I become a Muslim just like Jesus was a
Muslim Moses Abraham they're all Muslims
they submitted a gratis for the Muslim
is so if I accept Islam and I become a
Muslim do I have to give up my
collection of collection of VIP
nightclub nightclub cards you know and
the weekend fun time with the boys and
the partying you know do I have to give
this up how would you guys ask you this
during his lecture he explained with
some means yes sir
you explained with me that is that means
that means what is your sense -
surrender submission obedience sincerity
and peace so you submitting yourself to
the creator each and every single day in
obedience to him with sincerity so that
you can obtain peace in this life and in
the next the very definition of Islam
itself means that they're going to have
to be some things that are gonna have to
be weeded out things which are cut in my
life that are contrary and this goes for
Muslims this is not just you know just
new Muslim just goes for all Muslims
they're going to be things in our life
you don't have to weed out whatever we
find that our life that is contrary to
this meaning is going to have to be
removed because as he stated to be a
Muslim is an action word it is a verb it
means one who does Islam one who does
submit themselves to their creator each
and every single day with surrender and
obedience and sincerity in order to
attain peace so I'm doing something
contrary to that then I have some
problems go on one of my life and those
things are going to have to be removed
because if not you're gonna find
conflict and as Jesus peace be upon him
is supposedly have said in the Bible
that one heart cannot serve two masters
one heart cannot serve two masters for
it will either fall in love with one and
despise the other
or it couldn't of a book you never know
but it cannot have love and servitude
and obedience a surrendering and peace
to two different country audiologists
one of them is going to have to go one
is going to read itself out unless you
lead it out yourself and you
surely what's going to happen is the
negative is going to overpower just
because of the very structure of human
beings it's going to happen that way so
we're gonna have to leave those things
out yes but that's in an attempt to do a
slam and BMC in assignment or many
jolibois is recognized as the only one
who has the right to make lawful and
unlawful and the most most of the things
that we do those things that Allah has
made lawful there are more things that
are permissible and lawful then there
are that are not permissible so the
things that we used to do before we came
to this land we have come to know that
those things that are very hospitalized
and will only bring us destruction so
what is it to give up drinking alcohol
or using drugs or chasing women you see
or going out to the parties that's
nothing compared to the reward of peace
in this life and guidance and the
greatest reward to come into paradise
there I just wanted to just add
something to confirming what you said I
just came back as you know from Saudi
Arabia one of the shows that we're
producing from them we're not doing it
yet we need to get some more technicians
to help us finish it but it's called
love at the racetrack that's al Qaeda
love at the racetrack and we're talking
about racing horses now how can you
imagine as anything the movies like one
of the first things you observe when you
get there there's no gambling whatsoever
allowed you will be arrested if you
gamble another thing is there's no
alcohol without at all anywhere in the
kingdom so that's a whole different
picture in there but what we really
wanted to focus on whether it was also
the
advertise all of the signs that you saw
on there just said Allah Akbar spawn law
under lock grace God things like this
but when they were putting the horses
into the shoes our friend who was a
convert himself David Rogers and it was
beautiful because he would cooks the
horses into the shoes with words and
just inspired those horses and because
it horse whispering now this is an old
technique used by people that work with
animals that don't want to hurt them or
touch them they just want the animal to
cooperate we actually caught on camera
some of these brothers who don't know
inspect me try to push a horse in there
shoving it tugging at it with a row
behind it trying to drag it in the chute
it wouldn't go in the meantime David is
sitting on top of his horse talking to
another horse that they were trying to
load and he was skittish but you want to
include later when we got a chance to
get to the stables and properly and in
front of the horses he said all these
sources used to be afraid and skinny who
came up they would lend it outside of
the stall he said gonna just stand there
all over talking and watch what happens
so what we were doing what we're doing
right now cheers oh the horse would come
up and push the neck my head it is yeah
1 billion is sort of Hemi you know what
I mean wanna be on TV I guess I don't
know but he said the reason is horses
goodness a glove
the horse does what he does a love he
wants to please you
he wants so much to please you now I
understand I have a cat the same way
he's real over right in front of me
you're trying to walk the road over
right there once you turn back and then
put his head up against you and Kathy
will come
that loves why do these animals do what
they do and this was the whole point
that David Rogers want to make on each
other because they really will do what
they're supposed to do if they truly
love you and I love said about that
unicron only Gupta to people in the
lobby
yeah you know you become all well in a
vertical no no become full of authority
if you really love a wall if you really
no problem because then and will be then
a lot of looking and he will forgive
your sins he is the forgiver
he is from some of us that street life
who have tried to you know well and live
that life of maybe just ourselves have
you trying to fill ourselves with this
money like this pleasures come in the
morning you know bring anything you can
think of imaginable and
I know that it is not fair to my vision
for this life and one thing that I wish
is that all young people out there know
that it's this life as enticing you let
us be the I guess you could say that the
spokesman of the antithesis of that
that's not going to get you eaten
you know the only thing that we were
trying to do and I know my person was
trying to do was trying to put a bandaid
on the damage that I knew was inside of
me you know with these without alcohol
with the party with all that I was
trying to bandage the damage that was
inside of me that was like I had big
hole that I was trying to fill with the
experience but no for sure they're
trying to feel that this is one of my
first scholars that opportunity Riddler
that you suppose very well I'm saying
you need used to tell me that for a man
or a woman to try to feel that hole
inside of themselves their desires where
the things of this world you might as
well go through huge and try to feel the
ocean or sense because it is an
impossibility to do that you cannot feel
your desires anything
it's like trying to throw water out into
the ocean can you fill it hundred cans
and then he pointed the same of about
Mohammad PC of money that the only thing
of this world that will fulfill the
desires of the human being is the dust
of the grain that's the only time you'll
be satisfied is when we have put inside
that green so don't go chasing a life
that is going to bring you nothing but
in a full circle back to understanding
that you need something bigger and
greater in your life and don't mess up
and go that road this one a full circle
back to where you're sitting right here
and right now continuing on here with
our wonderful panel of guests on the
Dean Sean guide as TV
ya know so classic go to my room lock
the door go straight and cry thank God
you know me better than myself
show me the right way and I will not
look to how we leave everything behind a
lot of that greater and great everything
is intelligent to people
[Music]
and we want to the next question we got
several more questions but we got so
little time so we're going to try to get
through these quickly the next question
are you ready asking the tough questions
here on the Dean show is Sheikh Yusuf
Estes guide as TV Christians feel now
okay they feel Christ through the Holy
Spirit
Krishna's feel Christ through the Holy
Spirit
what internal proof does Islam offer
that's the question
talk to me let me let's go with Tahir
then we'll go to Yusuf and then we'll go
to but from the Islamic perspective is
referring to the angel of Revelation
Jeanine or Gabriel descriptions to the
prophets who receive scriptures Jesus
receiving the gospel Moses received over
the run he receives the scrolls of the
summer and Muhammad's humble or some
piece of quality can you see or not so
we have an understanding that the xperia
calling this is not a personal
experience what it is one that only
comes to the prophets investors
Jules
well I'm just going to answer the
question you asked how we find internal
evidence for the fly beneath system
there's a very beautiful person of our
honor
that pretty much sums it up for me where
Allah the Almighty Creator says no Quran
that in the remembrance of him do hearts
find rest and contentment and this is
the reality and I contend that coming
out of Christianity that you know they
had those emotional highs but that is
something that needs to be refurbished
to replenish those it dies very quickly
but there's something different about
them that can only be experienced the
only the experience is that contentment
that you find and remembering the one
two three or four things is the way he
wants to be remembered with that purest
and that oneness so internally the
evidence is only four is only in eyes of
the beholder it's not something that I
can cut out and someone else the
external evidences that God gives us is
part of that eternal evidence for us to
have peace in our lives and in the
remembrance of God do hearts find that
and then and the songs have stated the
real welcome is life isn't indignant
with whatever body whether it be good or
bad and that's one thing for sure I know
without trying to pass on religion the
Holy Spirit doesn't give you it might
give you that feeling when it's good
when things are good you might have that
enjoyment of the Holy Ghost but it's bad
because I spent a lot of years in
business and marketing providers and
what I remember about people being
filled with the spirit when he gets away
I'm on stage and he really out there
shouting telling you how this exciting
experience and how you doin how what I
am and I want to share this one I have
with you here's what I have for you
today we were all excited and the people
that knew it with that spirit of what he
was talking about but it wasn't even
Christianity wasn't even a limited that
was sellin Herbalife you know by
handling but it deal but this is here's
the proof you asked for it some life
does not know Arabic language at all yet
when they hear the words of the Quran in
the Arabic language and they start
crying what is that what is that because
when I first started the Quran decided I
was trying to convert a Muslim to be
pushed
yet every time he would recite I feel
like over over sight singing and slower
so that's nice I didn't know these
without the exact words recited to
Muhammad by the Holy Spirit the angel
Gabriel one of the most powerful moment
I used it when I was doing prison
chaplain work it's the verse in surah
bakra chapter 2 verse 2 p25 I recited
this one time and right next to where we
were holding our services some
Christians were over there we were here
we were trying to talk we couldn't even
hear ourselves the brother said you know
they
every time we're trying out service I
said though said then I think we should
know us together is I initiated on your
G miss middle wall my idea of how you
play center tune while at home this
summer what about Helen
muddy resposability yeah well they'll be
here me Masha Wasi of course EU who some
hot the while our well Lulu has the
people love me
under meets those last words these guys
became toda something and never made
another peep we had our services the
meaning of those words English language
says nothing in English so we'll bring
it I know I've tried many times I'll try
again tonight and then for those of my
arm I don't know about Islam Allah says
here that he's a lot but one disciple
there is none worthy of worship the ever
living the self-subsisting he does he
get tired he doesn't sleep then he asks
the question
of course he tells you that he is the
owner of all of the universe everything
in it heavens and earth blossom
now comes a rhetorical question who is
there he's asking who is there the guns
between me and my grace is permissible
so there's no intercession in his life
except that Allah gave me permission to
do such then he tells you that it's a
law that has all the knowledge of
everything you don't have any knowledge
so he his kursi extends all the universe
and he feels no fatigue and technical
and he is mighty and majestic thank you
show Yusuf and we have a couple more
question before this live filming of the
disha on guidance TV which Sheikh Yusuf
estimate on Sabri Sheikh metalia and
Joshua Evans hope everybody's enjoying
this episode and we're going to get into
the next question now the question is
asking Pete King Peter King just had
some hearings about the radicalization
of Miss some youth yes
what are your thoughts about this and as
Islam promote violence and
radicalization the way of the new
category denounces extremism in fact the
Prophet Muhammad
about it he said three times this lab
the terrorism all probably extreme
extremism is destroyed extremism will be
destroyed in between is three times so
assignment interpreters imbalance and
Margaret really like and it forbids us
to to go to extremes too far to the left
too far to the right now the hearing
that we witnessed by indicating Etsy to
know that the Senate committee of the
Judiciary Committee held another hearing
about two weeks later will do the flip
side of this hearing is Harry promoting
Islamophobia the other hearing in the
Senate promoted a more balanced
understanding of the rights that we as
Muslim family in this country so what
comes out this is balance even the men
it's almost you know a shame that we
have to defend ourselves on these types
of issues from these types of people
we have to get it recognition that is
undeserving because when we look at one
person saying that they are becoming a
continent an expert on the
radicalization of Muslims in America
when I own probably how many Muslim
separates welcome to my way question is
ever hosted I don't know actually these
ever stepped foot in the four thousand
plus that are in the United States of
America when in reality all three of us
including all four of us on this pathway
bubbly
you know circumvented you know the this
this entire system of my students and I
know at a time appreciate you
subscribing everyone that has a dress
someone addresses on them you know to
say that there is a problem with the
Magpies the Americans are not doing
enough to circumvent above themselves
that we have to ask the question why has
there not been a plethora of Muslims
extremists doing crazy things you know
as an outcome of this you know supported
discrimination that was
my eyes of materialism and extremism and
actually was saying very much yesterday
I asked him to reiterate this is he was
saying that there's not enough Muslims
saying anything about it there's not a
Muslim speaking out about it and this
one I'm gonna leave the Sheikh assume
that this very much have turned
according said it's turns out to be a
pretty much 90% Center thought would be
like mine so very companies like the
things we just kind of say that Devin is
dumb he had to say what you had to say
everybody has their right to say what
they want to say that's a constitutional
right afforded to us let us say we have
to say no when it comes to judging one
of the most important things about being
a Muslim is the truth even though it
says in the Quran chapter 17 verse 81
the truth of the Hopf will come and it
will destroy the battle
verily the truth will destroy the back
of the body will be destroyed by the
stream
Michael this falsehood hot and but this
is the subject was started with tonight
by the way we're talking about truth and
when I was listening to usually just
talking about this subject that when in
truth is there the alternate cannot
exist but when there is no truth then
there's lucky buddy exist except off
foot and we'll go back to when we said
all night long it's our responsibility
brothers and sisters and I'm saying
whether sisters in humanity even here
not Muslim
responsibility of a what you were here
tonight this is not something you can
ignore it's nice of you just one way mom
and say why I still want to believe this
or that well the truth is here it's
about all of us and as I'm
responsibility to say the truth now I'm
going to contradict you I'm going to
contradict you in a little bit of way
because I have to say the truth and
there are maybe four thousand questions
in the United States in 99.9% of all of
those are bringing out some of the best
of the youth that we have some of the
great view that we have here work on us
tonight
still that's not always the case there
are some Muslims when we misguided and
when some really stupid things and I
know that to be in fact because there's
a mushroom amounts across the street
from my house two houses down in other
words walk out through the street walk
for 60 seconds and you're inside the
muster
that's it you know it is you guys know
right it was in that exact
old house where five of our own brothers
in Islam conspired and drew up plans to
sneak off get on an airplane and fly the
Pakistan and jump off the plane and
declare jihad and I went to jail
immediately it was that smoothly
about these new then I found out when I
put some on the time I found out when I
came back that FBI agent standing on my
porch and then asked me what you could
teach these guys is what guys when they
start tell me what's going on and I'm
like oh my god now you hear something
about some boys and Rebecca said you
guys were stripping your house
whoa so we're know what you're teaching
lesson hygiene love it all the time I'm
out here and then they brought home
movies look at what the FBI said to me
they said how you go around the world
but you can't go across the street I
said what do you mean they said we've
seen your stuff
we know what you want and the mentioned
ooh by the way and they sell to each
other what do you think my tagging me
right
[Music]
but you know to me I miss them any now
they said we know you guys we know what
you're about and you know we want you to
teach this the realest line I was
shocked they were telling me that
literally said walk across the street
and start teaching these guys how do you
let this happen
and as they left I got thinking about if
the United States FBI is how you mean
say preacher preach I'm wondering about
regenerate think that know that you're
with us may I help all of us today
well we certainly managed you took the
opportunity to comment
it was great encouragement commend you
for the courage come out and eat with us
we have a question for you are you ready
to obey the one that along with our
partners on disturbs you if you believe
in God you would you consider this as a
way of life for you it becomes Maggie
said yes thank you said yes
who else would like to can find that
they want to believe in the one guy that
serving anybody else raise your raise
your hand no Maggie raised our hand to
us who else yeah but you raise your head
right mashallah
what's your name Oscar Oscar I like this
name
I just watch Sesame Street it's only
cooling on there right anyway it's nice
to have you guys with us tonight and we
do the menu and we make we don't need to
clap for you want to use something
better than this clapping it noise how
many of you Muslims if I say a prayer in
Arabic they'll say on me
okay I don't want yellow Vina so up the
most aki-nee and neatness around was
latina and he put that in English our
Lord guides to the straight path is
straight that whoever says this deep in
their heart a love about them and that's
what's up now
you started a piece we done with peace
peace brought to everybody that attended
and peace be unto you my guess
assalamualaikum
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you